our main story tonight concerns food or
as plants and animals might call it the
afterlife we we love food in America as
you would know if you've ever turned on
a television set I have eye candy
pancakes are back introducing all you
could eat wings Golden Corral everyone's
favorite endless shrimp is back people
wait for this promotion all year long
sadness sadness sadness let food replace
your sadness starry blitz did not hole
in your heart that's a catchy way to
sell hog scraps making barbecue sauce in
fact celebrating America often goes hand
in hand with celebrating its food what's
this actual commercial running right now
what's more American than a cheeseburger
this cheeseburger loaded with a hotdog
and potato chips in the hands of all
American models Samantha hoops in a hot
tub in a pickup truck driven by an
American bull rider on an aircraft
carrier under the gaze of Lady Liberty
as she admires the most American
thickburger new at Carl's jr. and
Hardee's Wow
a cheeseburger with hotdogs and potato
chips ladies and gentlemen I give you
the new Confederate flag she's majestic
no story about the food we eat it's a
story about the food we don't eat
because there is a surprising amount of
it
a report by the Natural Resources
Defense Council says that as much as 40%
of all the food produced in the United
States never gets eaten Americans throw
away 165 billion dollars worth of food
every year that's about 20 pounds per
person every month Americans throw away
enough food every year to fill 730
football stadiums food waste is like the
band Rascal Flatts it can fill a
surprising number of stadiums even
though many people consider it complete
garbage
Detroit produces sellers and consumers
Americans are throwing out a third or
more of our food and the amount we throw
out has increased by around 50% since
the 1970s at this rate in 40 years when
you order pizza from dominos
they'll just deliver it straight to the
nearest dumpster as they should but
that's not the point here if you think
that this sounds bad just wait until you
see how it looks
check out this waste dump in California
Salinas Valley we got a whole load
pretty much a loose organic lettuce you
know we've we've got spinach towards the
back looks like it's perfectly fine
nothing wrong with it we got some some
kale here we got broccoli in the back as
well we have plenty of produce to make a
salad here oh not just a salad you could
make a significantly better salad than
the salads they actually sell at
McDonald's which look like the trimmings
in Ronald McDonald's lawnmower mixed
with grimace ejaculate and the thing is
watching all that food go from farm to
not a table is awful for a bunch of
reasons first and most obviously there
are many people in this country who
needs that food in 2013 nearly 50
million Americans lived in food-insecure
households meaning that at some point in
the year they struggled to put enough
food on the table and the fact that we
throw away a third of our food gets
pretty alarming when you hear from some
of those people that's hard I'll go
without food before my kids will budget
down to the penny in it
it's not enough yeah it brings you the
tears yeah it's just hard they're so
young and it's hard it is crazy that
that is happening in a country with 730
football stadiums full of uneaten food
it's insane but there are also other
less obvious consequences to discarding
food for a start
we're wasting all the labor and natural
resources that went into making it and
at a time when the landscape of
California is shriveling up like a
pumpkin in front of a house with a lazy
dad it seems especially unwise the
farmers are pumping water into food that
ends up being used as a garnish for
landfills because those landfills go on
to cause problems of their own
if you were to throw an apple corer or
just out into the woods it's not a big
deal problem comes when all of that
waste is aggregated and it decomposes
without air in a landfill that anaerobic
condition is what creates methane which
is a greenhouse gas that's more than 20
times as potent as co2 at trapping heat
that's right when we dump food into a
landfill we're essentially throwing a
trash blanket over a flatulent food man
and Dutch oven in the entire planet and
if you're thinking but but hold on John
what if I'm an who couldn't give
a about America's hungry families
or the long-term viability of life on
Earth well first let me say mr. Trump
thank you so much for taking the time
secondly there is a selfish financial
reason for you to care about this story
- in our households were wasting
somewhere between 15 and 25 percent of
the food that we're buying you know
that's expensive
I mean imagine walking out of a grocery
store with four bags of groceries
dropping one in the parking lot and just
not bothering to pick it up and that's
essentially what we're doing in our
homes today and that's not good when
you're throwing away that much food
you're not just being wasteful you're
wining and dining raccoons oh this is
absolutely lovely thanks for this we
needed a break from the kids it's a good
thing so many of us have access to
plenty of relatively inexpensive food I
love the fact that we live in a country
with Cap'n Crunch peanut butter crunch
chocolatey crunch sprinkled donut crunch
cinnamon roll crunch Christmas crunch
and Halloween crunch I will even defend
oops or berries crunch a cereal so
unnecessary that its actual name
includes an apology for its existence
but it does seem it does seem like our
food wastage is getting to a critical
mass and so much of it stems from our
own habits and misconceptions
for instance stores big and small often
routinely overstock so that you can walk
in and see tons of food there because if
they don't do that as this small farm
stand operator describes it we might not
buy anything
and there was an hour left in the market
that one bunch of charge would sit there
and no one would buy it but if I had 30
bunches of charge of--like bursting out
I probably sell like 25 verses in charge
so what is that saving people are
totally imposters and they think if
there's one that there's something wrong
it's true I wouldn't buy that child
partly because it's charge but mainly
because we naturally assume the last
option is a bad option which in many
contexts is absolutely the case for
example you don't want the last magazine
in the doctor's office because it's
always Golf Digest always and no one has
ever read Golf Digest that's not even a
golf club in his hand but no one noticed
because it's on Golf Digest but when it
comes to produce the last option is
probably completely fine especially
because as another farmer explains even
slightly subpar fruits and vegetables
don't make it to the produce aisle every
time that the people are picking they'll
have a few they throw on the ground
because there's always a few that aren't
quite perfect this is a perfectly good
peach right on the ground like this oh
my god if you just look down this way
it's like a bounty look at that and the
reason that happens is that if a peach
doesn't meet strict aesthetic standards
it might not be worth a farmer even
trying to sell it our produce oils have
become a lot like Leonardo DiCaprio's
penis exclusively accessible to the
physically flawless
body-shaming is actually so ingrained
it's reflected in the USDA's grading
standards just look at the visual
grading standards for peaches this is a
number one peach and of course it is
that's an undeniably beautiful peach oh
I want to buy that peach dinner and
it whereas whereas embrace yourself this
is a number-2 peach and that is an
abomination unto the Lord and as soon as
it is labeled a number two it can lose
two-thirds of its market value to a
farmer even though its contents are the
same and many retailers have standards
even more strict than the USDA s all of
which is why so many peaches end up
being thrown on the ground to rot and
that should not be how we treat our
fruit it should only be how we treat our
celebrities so help me God Channing
Tatum you lose one muscle fiber on that
six-pack and I will personally toss you
into Hollywood's landfill you keep it
tight Tatum hashtag keep it tight tater
we don't just reject food because of how
it looks sometimes we do it out of pure
fear according to one estimate 91% of us
have thrown out food that's past its
sell-by dates because we're afraid it's
not safe and I am absolutely part of
that 91%
we're weirdly reverent towards these
dates even when they make no sense
use buy sell buy and nothing but just
that date and this is all the same brand
this is all the same brand this is not
only the same brand but also the same 2%
show us this shows there's a complete
confusion out there the only labels on
food more meaningless than those are the
ones on Smirnoff bottles that say triple
distilled vodka really Smirnoff so you
ran the potato sweats through the tube
sock two extra times thanks for spending
the effort we naturally assume sell by
dates reflect a uniform standard of
safety but that is not true well
actually there's nothing to do a safety
at all it's just a manufacturers best
guess of wine that food is gonna be the
freshest and at the best quality exactly
those dates are decided on by
manufacturers and if I were a food
manufacturer I would make those dates as
tight as possible to convince people to
buy a new one of my products because
unlike apple I can't just create a new
operating system that suddenly means
your old cereal is incompatible with
your mouth the truth is with the
exception of baby formula the federal
government does not require any food to
carry an expiration date and state laws
vary widely with nine states not
requiring any date labels at all which
means most of the time sell by dates are
one of those things that look official
but you can probably ignore like a child
in a cop uniform just to stop it Tyler
are not under a West you are under a
West
but because we think those dates are
real many supermarkets throw expired
food out even before its sell-by date
and they don't donate it for what they
think is a pretty good reason
everything that's closed dated or any
calls no we can't you can't it's a
safety you can't if you guys donate it
then or you don't donate it so if it was
straight in the garbage they go straight
in the garbage history losses have you
guys been sued before that's a common
misconception we all think that if you
donate food and someone gets sick if you
get sued I thought that until earlier
this week but we looked into it and
couldn't find a single case where a food
donor has been sued it doesn't happen
it's a false fear like believing if you
go in the water after eating you'll get
a cramp and drown yeah it turns out that
isn't true either this week has blown my
mind because the system is if you donate
food to a charity you're covered by the
Emerson Act which says you cannot be
sued if you make a food donation in good
faith you presumably get the same cover
with donating clothes even though in
some cases there you really should be
sued donating a cowl-neck sweater hello
the homeless live in shelters not for
Oh
yes here's the problem even if more
people understood that there would still
be food that doesn't get to people who
need it for a critical reason
Harold McClure D of HMC farms says he'd
like to donate more of his peaches to
the food banks but getting it into the
hands of somebody to eat it isn't isn't
free there's got to be an economic
incentive to move more of this into an
avenue that food banks couldn't take
advantage of it's a lot easier and
cheaper just to base it throw it away
and that may be the biggest issue of all
for businesses donating food is
genuinely expensive you've got to box it
store it coordinate deliveries for it
there's a lot of overheads
and you cannot fault companies for
caring about their bottom line in the
same way you can't fault a dog for
caring about licking its balls
it's what dogs do it's natural and dog
balls are delicious companies in their
defense are not charities which is why
they should be incentivized to donate
food with tax breaks large corporations
already get one but annoyingly that same
break for small businesses is not a
permanent part of the tax code meaning
that Congress has to keep renewing it
and that's a problem because family
farms or local restaurants may not know
if they're going to get that break at
the end of the year and therefore
whether donating food will be
financially viable for them it's a
ridiculous system which problem prevents
a lot of food from being donated so here
is the good news in February this year a
congressman proposed HR 640 for the
fighting hunger incentive Act to make
that tax break permanent here actually
is one of the bill's sponsors it's time
to get rid of these short-term fixes
embrace long-term solutions this
legislation simply makes the provisions
permanent and when you think about it
that's important because when
something's not permanent it affects our
behavior that's what we all treat rental
cars like we're in a fast and furious
movie I'm sorry sharp turn ahead get
ready to drift Kia Sorento
now now you'll be happy to hear that
bill passed the house however by the
time it did it had been bundled together
with other unpaid for tax breaks and
retitled the America gives more act but
still that original provision was in
there which means this problem has been
solved the show is over we can roll
credits and all live happily ever after
right no not right because when the bill
got to the Senate they and I honestly
did not know this was even possible they
removed everything from inside the bill
retitled it the trade facilitation and
trade Enforcement Act of 2015 and
refilled it with completely different
language concerning border control and
us-israeli relations which meant yes HR
644 passed just with a completely
different title and completely different
contents it's like going to a restaurant
ordering a veggie burger and having the
way to say here you go we made out of
meatloaf and we call it a waffle and
then you can't even say well I don't
want this give it to someone who needs
it because they can't because they don't
know whether or not they'll get a
tax credit for it
the same thing everyone basically agrees
small businesses should get tax
incentives to donate food so we have to
find a way to pass that but even if we
do it will be one small part of what
needs to be a much bigger solution from
and resolving to eat uglier fruit to
taking expiration dates with a pinch of
salt to no longer worrying about getting
sued by high-powered lawyers
representing the hungry
we all have to address our relationship
with food waste or at the very least our
cheeseburger commercials are gonna have
to get a lot more honest what's more
American than a cheeseburger this
cheeseburger loaded with a hot dog and
potato chips in the hands of a model in
a hot tub in a pickup truck on an
aircraft carrier in front of the Statue
of Liberty I'll tell you what's more
American if that cheese burgers that
thrown away along with 15 other
cheeseburgers in front of a food
insecure family for who frankly cannot
believe their eyes as they stand on top
of 14 tons of perfectly edible if
aesthetically unappealing fruits and
vegetables which in turn sits on top of
80 tons of dairy products all one day
patched their arbitrary sell-by dates
all of which sits inside a tear rolling
down Abraham Lincoln's face on Mount
Rushmore which is now nearly chin deep
and millions of discarded cheeseburgers
all gradually decomposing and emitting
flammable methane
red white and blue that is king of
America I think that this can cost you
in your hardest
you